hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing height Luka yes hi sugar and
this is a funny name is that an animal I
have no idea maybe this is some some
German expression that is not from from
my area of Germany and sometimes have
that okay this should be - it's very
looks a little bit conservative let's
aim it's not like a scotch for nerds
with reverse colors I can definitely
play in the same in the same way with
black like age six well no I can no I
cannot do it c4 is an active means but
what's the deal I mean let's start with
this put some pressure on the form
yeah Queen to f6 is that a move or is
said silly it could be a very silly
decision putting the Queen right
opposite to the bishop somehow I still
like the idea some natural moves are not
that easy for white to play I mean stuff
like okay 22 is nonsense for example
okay so funny funny way of playing would
be I was thinking about something
entirely different
I thought to Queen B three Queen f4
something like that
anyway he's covering the bishop so d5
becomes more of an option
so how how are we handling this
I can try Queen jf4 it's a really odd
means trying to provoke g3g 320 twin h6
was my idea yeah all the sounds are not
to disturb me but the window open I will
definitely close it soon I need some
fresh air into this place I wish they'd
wonder what hydraulic with hydraulic Oh
her ladyship it's a she anyway
Bishop to c1
before I know that looks really odd but
I don't know what he's doing against it
this one okay eh I guess
Oh a blunder b7 okay not really
b7 good night I'm going to close the
window to be too loud okay what is hi to
look up to Queen a for what's going on
here 92 is that the point
I guess it was a threat
oopsy one okay I was thinking Bishop f4
here we should have 492 don't have much
time
[Music]
I thought even Queen takes if three is
possible but it's a bit a bit too much
Mary
at the end the question is what about
the center okay I can take it 300g get
with chick no don't have many squares
admittedly
let's see how to do this I wanted to go
there anyway don't think 96 is going to
happen okay I should have taken it yeah
yeah
white lost a bit contribute of control
here when we got to the time the time
trouble phase and stuff the same it's a
complicated position here that it's
varied in a way very concrete and solid
tactical 3 I went back b1 yeah the
engine likes white at least initially
it's not really a significant depth but
it's totally possible then white is
better you have to ship C 1 and Queenie
4 I wanted to keep things complicated
and he'll be should be 3 about strong
yeah okay I actually didn't really I was
only thinking that this is okay but like
if you continue for one more move you
wonder what your next move is with black
him that is just enormous you don't have
a minute just looks ahead bad so that
was a huge opportunity for white and
that is also not easy at all
I shot g6 no Bishop f4 seems fine 92 I
actually a briefly thought that this
could be a movie I think that it should
be playable King moves I guess and
take here I defy this a thing okay
otherwise it's kind of interesting i've
got i've got a pawn
two minor pieces and excellent
coordination good pieces 95s the engines
mean which is really a remarkable move I
mean for the moment I only have two
points and the piece for the Queen but
two pieces are hanging and the engine
gives Y just smallish advantage through
your market well
okay Queen f5 is the more sober move
friend yeah I'm definitely fine
and here f5 is strong and I that's not
that was not within my powers I mean
we're here look at look at this it's
kind of yeah you kind of see that that
is probably strong but it's not I didn't
see it iam that is not all that clear I
know why this is active oh I could have
just taken that oops oops I could have
just taken that I mean I didn't have
much time but still I should see that I
was just completely focused on
consolidating and I managed to consult
and then Danny yeah blundered into this
huge hawk yeah the Queen God's got two
taken yeah okay thanks a lot for
watching